I want to see what's going on in your
mouth
I kind of got a great idea they go by
two chain two chains on the over-the-top
sometime right now we want to check out
the most expensive [ __ ] [ __ ] definitely
Christ what up
it's 2 Chainz and we back most expensive
is [ __ ] and it's next product damn -
bird it's really gonna blow your socks
away - thrush people I mean what's the
most will you play for - for like maybe
what 40 maybe 50 dollars for not in
charm the rod knifes in Germany it's the
most expensive - person to work let's
check it out me - dog is going on in
here I'm here to talk about the most
expensive toothbrush here this thing
right yeah this tooth words it looks
like it's from the Jetsons or something
like that well now I got an oral beat
that I have to plug up it cost me about
20 bucks this one is a little smaller
than that and you mean to tell me it's
more expensive this is way marks this is
made out of titanium it has a patented
coating and it's antibacterial so it's
gonna help them fight the bacteria that
cause cavities and this is going to help
you have a beautiful healthy smile a
beautiful healthy smile is priceless
you use your smile all day long the
first thing people see right it's
titanium it has a patent and for some
antibacterial stuff that no other
toothbrush can have the company we nest
is gonna send the bristles to the owner
of the toothbrush which is going to be
you every month you're gonna change the
bristles on the brush so this brush is
gonna actually last you a lifetime
a more
nema says to China you see that last
name change people so how much is this
expensive to first I can I would like to
take a guess this one is titanium it has
the special pad I say this two-person
$99 this toothbrush is 3,200 euros which
is over $4,000 are you serious people
say you know how can I spend so much
money for a toothbrush but you use this
brush at least twice a day for the rest
of your life how many things do you buy
like your car sit in the garage or your
change sitting there and you're both
somewhere and the only way your favorite
one but this is something that you're
gonna use twice a day for the rest of
your life how many times a day do you
brush your feet twice in the morning at
night you use dental floss I use
mouthwash do you use dental floss before
or after your breath before very good
most people for us but they don't always
trust properly make the floss wrap it
around your middle fingers i rub around
my index but you tell them yesterday if
you wrap it around the index finger you
all like tied here and you can't move it
around so wrap it around your middle
fingers and then grab on to it with your
point to end your thumb and you can move
it around and it's a good waxy kind of
floss to where it kind of just slides in
there incoming yeah now this is a $5,000
toothbrush that I'm about to use it's
right on my shop brush you should take
you two minutes two full minutes two
minutes is a very long time okay so this
is what we want to do one second hold on
back up you could spit you could spit
don't worry I'm - this tastes like
titanium you kind of all over the place
when you brush your teeth like that
you're gonna miss some spots and you
really want to scrub around stimulating
the gums and cleaning your people but
you want to take this all the way around
all right perfect
so today I learned about the most
expensive to personal work and that
expert that 5000 [ __ ] dollars
for a toothbrush 3,200 euros you know
euros are as [ __ ] ridiculous no no
you tell me what you think leave a
comment subscribe to the GQ channel for
more most expensively [ __ ]